- Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
What you're seeing over
the next few videos
are analyses of charts and data
that are put together
by "The New York Times"
around trends in wealth,
income, and income inequality.
Our goal here is to
give you extra context,
extra ways to analyze the data,
maybe a lens that might not be obvious
when you first look at
some of these graphs.
Now all of us here at Khan Academy,
our goal, we're a
not-for-profit with a mission
of providing a free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere, is
to provide the supports
so that you can look at the data
and come up with your own judgments.
Our goal is not to project any opinion
or any view onto you,
but to give you the tools you need
to form your own beliefs
or your own analyses.
So take a look at these videos.
Hopefully, they will surface insights
on some of the data, some
of the visualizations
that might not have
been obvious otherwise,
and they inform all of us
on a very important debate
in the world and
especially in this country
around how have incomes trended,
how has the distribution
changed over time,
and where might we be
going and for what reasons.